can you ice-cream it Nacho Cheese
Doritos to junk foods that are great for
stoned people it looks like cat food
whoa I hated it but now I kind of want
more the texture is an abomination but
the flavor is great
I like Doritos and I like ice cream but
I do not think they should be together I
kind of love it actually it's kind of
exactly what you think it tastes like
which is garbage smoked salmon and cream
cheese ice cream it kind of tastes good
that's very fishy smells really weird
I'm not kidding that's not bad that's
not terrible yeah I could eat that I
didn't like that salmon no yes
bagel bite ice cream and I have some
carbs with those carbs Bagel Bites kind
of have a pretzel lead dough and you can
really taste that here it's amazing I'm
not getting any of the cheese it's just
like bread and ice cream no do you think
it's gonna be horrible and it's very
horrible sriracha ramen ice cream nah I
don't think that I like noodles and ice
cream it's creamy it's spicy and there's
ramen in it this kind of tastes cousin I
don't know how to react to this my taste
buds are just like all over the place
right now I would eat a small thing of
this yes this isn't no yes Oh No No
the corn and M&Ms I'm gonna keep an open
mind but this looks like a nightmare I
don't like it oh wait I like it I guess
it's like creamed corn that's a thing
right a lot going on in this one that's
so strange it actually tastes good yes
pass sort of it yes it's kind of perfect